bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur tv
fils une heure pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale toujours en direct du
lundi au jeudi et merci de nous
rejoindre il est 18 heures dans un
instant nous parlerons handicap et
l'accessibilité des villes en question
l'association des paralysés de france a
publié son baromètre annuel un rapport
sera remis aussi cette semaine par le
gouvernement par une sénatrice de
l'essonne les villes ont elles fait des
efforts que reste-t-il à faire surtout
en plateau vous les avez vu la maire
adjointe de versailles en charge des
affaires sociales et la représentante
départementale de la pf dans les
yvelines pour l'instant voici les titres
de ce 25 février quelques-uns des autres
sujets que nous allons développer ce
soir plus de 30 he la verrière et la
défense
et ce pendant deux à trois semaines
c'est la conséquence d'un incendie
survenu ce week end au poste de
signalisation deux-sèvres des policiers
yvelinois dans la rue ce lundi ils ont
manifesté devant la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique à
viroflay pour protester contre un mode
de réorganisation vous les entendrez
aussi sur le plateau tout à l'heure et
puis du sport également ce soir avec
notamment perrine sanchez championne du
monde de chute libre là le portrait de
cet hymne inten qui est venu à ce sport
un peu par hasard rencontre lors d'un
entraînement et du horse ball à la base
de loisirs de saint quentin 7e journée
du championnat régional sept équipes en
compétition dont un club du big noise
celui de chapet le plus grand club de
horse ball de france et du sport il y en
aura aussi dans la seconde partie de
cette édition avec le 7-8 sport bonsoir
anthony bonsoir wilfried est au menu de
ce sept huit sports du tennis de table
nous ferons un point mi saison avec
l'entraîneur de l'entente des féminines
de voisins st-arnaud geoffrey nisand qui
entame et qui continuent d'ailleurs leur
belle aventure en nationale 2 nous nous
projetterons sur la saison 2013
également de la base de loisirs saint
quentin en yvelines et nous vous ferons
découvrir les cheerleaders les
supportrices numéro 1 des templiers
d'elancourt et comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end ring pour les cheerleaders
rester avec nous ce sera seconde partie
de cette édition aux alentours de 18h30
si vous nous suivez en direct pour
l'instant l'actualité du jour c'est cet
incendie sur une installation électrique
entre sèvres ville d'avray qui va priver
de nombreux habitants de transilien
pendant plusieurs semaines 25000 c'est
le chiffre de cette édition 25 mille
voyageurs qui empruntent matin soir
cette ligne eu entre la verrière et la
défense il vont devoir utiliser des
solutions alternatives l incendie s'est
déclaré vers 4 heures du matin il ne
serait pas criminel il en d'honneur
demeure pas moins que les dégâts sont
d'envergure toutes les précisions avec
valerio ribot
55 mille voyageurs sont concernés depuis
ce matin aucun train ne circule sur la
ligne e du transilien
cette ligne reliant la verrière à la
défense est fermé en raison d'un
incendie survenu dimanche à 4 heures du
matin à la station sèvres ville d'avray
un peu ceux de relais qui commande la
circulation
ah c'est vrai ce lundi seule la moitié
des trains au départ de versailles rive
droite circulent la ligne u quant à elle
est totalement condamné pour deux à
trois semaines aucun bus supplémentaire
ne sera mise en service une solution
insuffisante face au volume d'usagé trop
important la sncf encourage les
voyageurs à s'orienter vers la ligne c
du rer et le tramway t2 vers la défense
pour l'heure aucune mesure
d'indemnisation n'est envisagée
chaque année l'association des paralysés
de france établi un baromètre de
l'accessibilité les villes les plus
accessibles sauf seuls les chefs lieux
des départements sont étudiés cette
année grenoble arrive en tête avec une
note de 18,14 4 sur 20 pardon à
versailles et 26e avec 14,3 sur 20 c'est
l'une des plus importantes progressions
parmi les différentes villes étudiées en
un an une vingtaine de places gagnées
bonsoir à corinne bobin vase est ce donc
maire-adjointe de versailles en charge
des affaires sociales et puis bon soir à
l'illiade morlec vous êtes représentant
du conseil départemental de la pf dans
le département avant de parler justement
du cas de versailles en quoi ce
classement est encourageant parce qu'on
peut dire en tout cas qu'il est parce
que les nôtres sont meilleurs que
l'année dernière ont peut-être c'est
encourageant mais par rapport à la loi
de 2015 où tout doit être accessible et
encore beaucoup à faire et ça c'est la
conséquence de la loi handicap de 2005
d'obliger les communes être voilà que
c'est totalement accessible thermale
félicie penser qu'elle ne sera pas en
2015 comment vous mesurer justement avec
ce baromètre quels sont les critères qui
rentrent en ligne de compte bella année
les critères c'est surtout sur la chaîne
de déplacement
sur les bâtiments publics qui ne sont
pas accessibles
et sur balles pour halle pour pouvoir
aller travailler et pour pouvoir aller
se déplacer pour les loisirs à quoi sert
véritablement alors ce baromètre parce
que vous nous le dites la situation
reste tout de même finalement un petit
peu inquiétante puisque il ya encore
beaucoup à faire on le verra tout à
l'heure mais à quoi sert véritablement
ce baromètre a alerté justement les
communes a alerté les communes qu'il est
temps puisqu'il reste plus que deux ans
qui est le
l'accessibilité doit être fait en 2015
et les communes auront la possibilité en
deux ans de rattraper ce retard je ne
pense pas ça sera compliqué ce sera
compliqué il ya tout de même une
progression a malgré tout sur les
différentes villes des différents chefs
lieux des départements qui sont étudiées
seulement quatre villes n'ont pas la
moyenne cette année elles étaient 15
l'an passé et même une accélération des
des choses et puis vous l'avez dit c'est
une obligation légale il reste seulement
deux ans pour se mettre aux normes mises
accessibilité est de tous les bâtiments
recevant du public ce sera obligatoire à
partir du 1er janvier 2015 il ya tout de
même beaucoup de dérogation autour de ça
aussi oui mais si on voulait
et puis pas que ça c'est discriminatoire
puisque les personnes peuvent hélas pas
c'est toute une chaîne les personnes
peuvent pas aller travailler ne peuvent
pas avoir des loisirs sont à chaque fois
tributaire de
de transport qui sont parfaits qu'ils
sont pas adaptés ou mal fait ou mal
conçus et c'est le problème encore à
l'heure actuelle quand on voit quelques
images de la ville de versailles
justement versa et qui aujourd'hui est
notée 14,3 sur 20/26 ville vous avez
progressé d'une vingtaine de places
comment vous avez réussi cette
progression quels sont les efforts que
vous avez réalisé sur un an alors les
notre priorité c'était bien sûr la mise
en accessibilité au regard de la
mobilité mais c'est un plan pluriannuel
que les communes sont tenues en fait de
mettre en oeuvre les budgets sont votés
annuellement sur un programme qui
concerne la voirie les bâtiments publics
les écoles très important les écoles et
puis bien sûr les transports alors on a
un partenariat très étroit avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la vie de la
cité le château de versailles
l'université de saint quentin fébus donc
la société transports et puis au sein
des services de la ville
les services de la petite enfance les
services de l'éducation
et puis nos partenaires publics
institutionnels que peuvent être la sncf
versailles est doté de cinq gars
est également les commerçants alors les
commerçants et c'est une grosse
difficulté à versailles puisque nous
sommes quand même une des villes qui a à
la fois là la chance d'avoir un
patrimoine historique de grande renommée
et le château de versailles et contribue
à contribuer à cette renommée mais
souvent voilà les petits commerçants
occupent des locaux qui sont
difficilement accessibles sans remettre
en cause cette ce patrimoine alors
néanmoins les commerçants bien compris
que versailles étant une ville dont 22%
de la population est âgée que finalement
le service de proximité de convivialité
et
de toute façon un moyen de conserver
leur chiffre d'affaires quand ils sont
concurrencées par internet ou
concurrencé par un grand centre
commercial avoisinants et de concours
technique ou même parce que même s'ils
ont la volonté de le faire alors il ya
des contraintes techniques ont gagné un
tri moines par exemple une des raisons
de notre mobilisation c'est que nous
sommes de convaincu qu' il est très
important d'être dans l'esprit de la loi
c'est à dire que parfois vous avez des
le cadre bâti vous impose des
contraintes mais parfois il suffit de
modifier en fonctionnement donc c'est
tout un état d'esprit qu'il faut
modifier pour permettre justement et
bien deux
rendre ce service là accessible et ça
nécessite de l'innovation de la
créativité et ça je crois que la ville
de versailles
justement avec ce support historique et
un petit peu qui pourraient être
qualifiés de
regardant vers le passé est tenue à
cette innovation et cette créativité et
j'ai bon espoir puisque dans la
commission d'accessibilité nous avons
intégré l'école nationale d'architecturé
et je voudrais vraiment amener les
architectes à réfléchir tout simplement
pour moi à une conception universelle
c'est-à-dire que vous comme moi nous
serons amenés à vieillir et sans doute à
être dans nos logements et à avoir
besoin est bien de circuler dans nos
logements de manière beaucoup plus
fluide et sans obstacle donc ce que
demande
cette catégorie de population qu'on
appelle handicapés dans la loi de 2005
est tout simplement une demande de droit
commun qui va rencontrer les besoins de
chacun d'entre nous donc c'est presque
une politique de bon sens que il s'agit
de mener tous ensemble ça vous rassure
d'entendre ça c'est une politique de bon
sens déjà il ya des efforts qui sont
faits et fort de faire dit encore trop
trop peu par à pau qu'est ce que
aujourd'hui véritablement qu'est ce qui
manque aujourd'hui véritablement quels
sont les efforts qui ne sont pas faits
les domaines où les difficultés sont les
plus importants il existe au cours des
mairies qui ne sont même pas accessibles
donc dans la région il ya des mairies
qui s'opposait plus accessible et parce
que l'on évoque le cas de versailles
puisque versailles fait partie des chefs
lui étudié mais on est là mais il ya
enfin la pf n'a pas étudié de l'ensemble
des communes hart man ou même de france
alors que c'est qu'on sait pertinemment
que les travaux c'est que 1% du des
prêts
des travaux il n'y a pas énormément à
faire mais c'est toujours nommé toujours
en avant les problèmes économiques
comme quoi on peut pas ne pas effectuer
les travaux les problèmes économiques
les problèmes de patrimoine aussi on les
a évoqué tout à l'heure quel que soit le
bâtiment quelle que soit la structure
aujourd'hui pour la paix est filée il
est possible en tout cas si on veut on
peut de trouver les solutions si on veut
on peut trouver des solutions parce que
comme je vois au niveau du château de
versailles qui était quand même qu'il
quand même un monument et sur lequel il
ya vue de l'accessibilité de fait qu'il
ya eu des améliorations ont été faites
donc je me dis que j'aime bien et bien
des choses qui pourraient être
modifiées autre point qui est
intéressant que vous avez soulevé ce
travail avec l'école d'architecturé
notamment parce que c'est très bien de
penser aujourd'hui aux travaux pour les
bâtiments qui qui ne sont pas aux normes
et qu'il faut mettre aux normes mais il
ya l'avenir aussi est-ce que les
bâtiments qui aujourd'hui sont conçus
réponde à toutes les exigences c'est
quand ya pas de dérogation parce que
malheureusement il arrive qu'il y ait
des dérogations et
que c'est pas mis en place parce que bon
bah il ya des petits passe-droits et
puis les bâtiments publics ne sont pas
ne sont pas mieux non et dans ces cas là
la pf fait entendre qu'elle se fait
entendre et on risque même par la suite
de faire des opérations coup de poing
pour justement
on est bien ce problème vous avez
peut-être certaines situations certains
cas dont département au delà on pas je
les ai pas comme ça en tête mais caveau
est vigilante voilà c'est un bon gars et
on est obligé d'être vigilants pourquoi
on est une accessibilité on n'a pas le
choix obligés d'en arriver là quoi le
handicap est il bien pris en compte dans
votre ville nous sommes allés vous posez
la question aujourd'hui voici quelques
réponses des yvelinois
je leur ai que c'est un problème qui
commence à être pris en considération
je vois de plus en plus des accès aux
handicapés des des repères pour les
handicapés et des places de parking pour
les sommes dues copines pour les
handicapés ya pas assez de confort dans
par exemple dans les restaurants c'était
trop petit par exemple ceux qui sont en
fauteuil roulant parce qu'il ya quelques
progrès à faire pour eux je trouve que
c'est un peu limité surtout dans les
magasins ya passé places de parking pour
les handicapés les voix vous avez une
place et puis les trottoirs les gens qui
se garent n'importe où rien n'est fait
il ya des règles des flics et où elles
sont impliquées dans certains endroits
mais je pense qu'il ya besoin
effectivement dans les centres
commerciaux et dans certains lieux de
les réadapter encore un peu nu ça reste
difficile et je pense qu'il faut se
mettre à leur place pour bien comprendre
que c'est pas si simple que ça le
constat est le même les efforts sont
faits mais ils sont encore ils ne sont
pas encore suffisants c'est ce que ce
que vous disiez comment ça va se
dérouler pour les prochains mois
d'ailleurs pour cette ville de
versailles pour progresser encore et
augmenter cette note de 14,3 que la paix
vous a décerné cette année
l'accessibilité ne concerne pas
exclusivement les déplacements et
concerne aussi d'autres types de
handicaps que sont la suite la cécité la
surdité et puis la déficience
intellectuelle voire psychique et ses
sujets ces handicaps là sont parfois
invisible et compensant handicap
fauteuil pour l'accessibilité voilà
c'est bon c'est pas le seul il faut
prendre en compte tous les handicaps
voilà la loi du 11 février 2005 indique
bien
la définition prend bien en compte les
quatre types lui-même cinq types de
handicap dans les deux sens auriel et
nous avons cette volonté justement de
considérer en fait l'ensemble de la cité
comme étant accueillante pour tous types
de vulnérabilité en fait on peut très
bien tous être amené à moins bien voir à
moins bien entendre à être décontenancé
par un afflux d'informations trop
important je dis toujours que en étant
au châtelet les halles fatigue et un
soir de retour du du bureau et bien on
est en situation de déficience
intellectuelle parce qu'on ne comprend
pas on n'arrive pas à traiter
l'information à la règle et est tout
l'enjeu est de travailler ces questions
de communication adaptés de
communications simplifiées le château de
versailles travaille sur ces sujets là
de pouvoir tout simplement
développer des circuits qui permettent à
des personnes qui n'ont pas notre
culture
d'appréhender des espaces qu'on met à
leur disposition notamment touristiques
et pour ce qui est de la communication
simplifié ou adaptés on voit bien que
les premiers bénéficiaires sont nos
touristes quand on voit les 10 millions
de touristes qui viennent fréquentait la
ville de versailles des chinois des
japonais qui ne lisent pas le français
qui ne comprennent pas le français ont
besoin d'outils qui leur permette
d'accéder là encore on est sûr de la
conception universelle c'est voilà c'est
que c'est
une manière de voir les choses qui
aujourd'hui
et force de proposition créateurs de
richesses d'innovation et je crois que
la france a tout à fait la possibilité
d'aller sur ce champ là et de créer de
nouvelles technologies de nouveaux
outils pour répondre à des besoins qui
aujourd'hui sont spécifiques mais qui
demain sont unis seront universel ce
sont des innovations véritablement qu'il
faut réaliser nous le dit mais ça a un
coût aussi est ce qu'il ya une enveloppe
budgétaire chaque année justement pour
le handicap l'accessibilité pour la
ville de versailles alors oui
les enveloppes et budgété et croissante
depuis depuis plus de cinq ans est ce
qu'il faut savoir sur la ville investit
chaque année l'année dernière c'était
sept cent mille euros
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce
sont les budgets spécifiques et ce qui
est très important c'est d'anticiper
d'anticiper dans les travaux
l'adaptation par exemple de la voirie
pour nous c'est très important quand on
va réaliser un des travaux de voirie
d'avoir bien en amont fait le circuit
avec la pf pour bien voir les endroits
où justement on va profiter de ces
travaux pour faire les aménagements à
rayer avec les communes justement je
vous interromps mais pour savoir comment
se passe le travail entrepris par
exemple entre la ville de versailles et
la pm vous avez travaillé ensemble nous
on travaille aussi on fait beaucoup les
commissions communales d'accessibilité
sur toutes les villes
donc pour ça pour justement qui est une
amélioration piqué est ça la plupart
dans beaucoup de villes ce n'est même
pas mis en place
malgré les obligations malgré les
obligations ne s'y soumettent pas bien
rapport qui est attendue aussi dans les
prochains jours c'est celui de la
sénatrice claire lise campion sur
l'accessibilité la pf qui a participé a
été auditionnée ce rapport vous en
attendez quoi
que les choses se débloquent quelque
chose avec aurait vite plus rapidement
on a besoin vraiment ma tombe dans un
bain dans un système où les handicapés
c'est plus des personnes qui restent
enfermées chez elles elles sont vraiment
besoin de sortir avoir une vie une vie
familiale une vie une vie de loisirs une
vie ronan on a vraiment envie de se
tourner vers le monde extérieur est pas
vivent dans un monde clos et
c'est pas possible quoi il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à
débattre de cinq ans et puis l'impératif
l'obligation légale 1er janvier 2015
vous nous l'avez dit ce sera difficile
pour de nombreuses communes de s'y
soumettre à cette obligation d'accepter
perdre de vue qu'il faut qui même si ici
2015 qui est la date butoir ne sera pas
malheureusement pas ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut le faire et qu'ils soient qui
baissent les bras et qu' il n'y ait pas
une continuité de fait dans ce domaine
merci à toutes les deux d'être venu je
rappelle donc cette 26ème place pour la
ville de versailles cette progression
d'une vingtaine de places avec les
efforts comme était engagé on verra l'an
prochain comment vous êtes classé par
rapport à la pf avec cette note de 14,3
on verra si elle progresse encore merci
donc à toutes les deux dans un instant
sur ce plateau la colère des policiers
moulinois va s'exprimer ils dénoncent la
réorganisation qui va s'opérer dans les
prochains mois pour une partie des
services ils vont nous expliquer
pourquoi ils manifestaient aujourd'hui
pour l'instant l'inauguration du nouveau
mille club à maurepas la structure pour
les 11 17 ans a fait peau neuve avec
toujours le même objectif proposer des
activités des sorties et être un lieu de
ressources pour les adolescents
autour c'est encore un peu le chantier
le centre de loisirs mille clubs dédiés
aux 11-17 ans a inauguré ce week-end à
maurepas son nouveau bâtiment habillé de
bois construit à quelques mètres de
l'ancien préfabriqué au toit pyramidal
devenu inadapté même si le mobilier la
décoration ne sont pas prêts les jeunes
ont déjà pris possession des lieux on va
bénéficier de deux salles alors qu'on
avait juste une salle qui était pas
forcément super vite et l'isoler donc là
c'est vraiment celle au confort absolu
confort absolu avec une surface au sol
qui passe de 110 à 170 m² environ et
surtout une structure moderne labellisé
thx et hpe très haute performance
énergétique
chauffée par une pompe à chaleur
géothermique
grâce à ce nouvel aménagement de 900000
euros financés par la mairie et les
subventions du département et de la
région les projets vont pouvoir mieux se
développer on a une moyenne en matière
de 30 35 jeunes par jour mais on
pourrait pas accueillir les 200 en même
temps même si on entre 200 et 300
inscrits mais ça nous permet en tout cas
de mieux structurer ces accueils et
surtout au niveau de l'accompagnement à
la scolarité de pouvoir faire des
espaces différents c'est un projet qu'on
a développé puis l'année dernière donc
il développe de plus en plus les
activités au sein du nouveau mille club
reprendront lundi 4 mars pour les
vacances scolaires des jeunes ont
d'ailleurs profité de l'inauguration
pour s'inscrire la carte jeune
morlaisien coûte 6 euros 75 par an pour
les séjours et sorties thématiques le
tarif est évalué selon une grille
tarifaire en fonction des quotients
familiaux un atelier d'initiation au
graffiti avec un professionnel est
prévue mercredi 13 mars certains ont
déjà commencé